curve ce l'ho anch'io se non lo faccio
vedere perché serve un po però ce l'ho
anch'io le cure
io divertimento per tutti sì sì abbiamo
capito che abbiamo fatto questo gioco
per divertirci fammi giocare però che
bello che sembra dice mio zio che
ammazza la gente
bene tutti ragazzi per questo video io
salto la intro e sono fa vj e siamo su
serial clymer clean cleaner il gioco
utilizza i dati reali del mondo per
influenzare gameplay quindi usa il tuo
ip per determinare la tua posizione nel
mondo reale che cosa gli serve questa
cosa
ok ecco infatti harrower dpa sono in una
posizione nel mondo ignota quindi milano
non l'ha trovato il posto dove quindi
non lo fate ste cagate sono riuscite
siamo su serial cleaner ragazzi prima di
spiegarvi in gioco nelle opzioni
linguaggio e cambiamo in italiano che
sicuramente c'è che sicuramente c'è che
non se lo caga mai nessuno italiano pro
c'è il polacco che molto strano che non
ci sia l'italiano come sempre
che strano e non ci siamo g min di
incredibile story con tracks
io non sono anche di cosa stiamo
parlando quindi ok usic cleaner sì sì
posso usare il joystick che sono pigro
come lo schifo by joystick wow
fantastico io devo prendere gli oggetti
va bene cosa devo fare io devo prendere
l'indizio porca vacca gli omessi
macchina io avessi non mi hanno
picchiato vabbè body hi anche il corpo
devo prendere va bene quindi devo devo
andare devo passare non fossi passare di
qua non sono magro vabbè ma io se gli
passa vicino mi vedono mi vedono
ma quindi io devo nascondere il corpo
per quale motivo non ho capito il motivo
di questa cosa
prendetevi vi spiego e c'è stato un
omicidio
ok e quindi io devo nascondere le prove
le prendo le nascondo tipo il corpo e
l'orologio le prende
ecco così io ho fregato tutti quanti i
poliziotti via
e proprio il mio lavoro questo 45 minuti
dopo aver guidato a casa è allora un po
di resina questa qua mia nonna e mia
mamma o babbi bobby caro sto facendo i
pancakes vuoi la marmellata o il burro
d'arachidi burro da clima ma come la
marmellata ma che schifo che fai
cioè io vado a pulire gli omicidi e poi
torna a casa c'è mia mamma che mi fai
panini con la marmellata gioco dell'anno
20 euro spesi benissimo pronto amazon
amazon per i morti
mamma sto uscendo che devo lavorare tu
che cosa fai
le bollette sono arrivate puoi andare
poi a pagarle si va da lavorare prima
pole e pago ecco esatto esattamente
quello che ha detto lo your bed
grazie tesoro sente zero grazie mamma
sei una mamma
devo andare ragazzi devo fare il mio
sporco lavoro il mio pulito lavoro i
miei contatti al telefono ammazzano la
gente e io vado qua per pulire mentre
c'è la polizia
porca vacca nasconditi nasconditi non ci
si nasconde qua stato il tipo non ha
mica visto che è sparito un corpo o
marca vacca ci sono passata ci sono
passato che è difficilissimo sto gioco
sembra una cagata ma veramente difficile
prendi il corpo subito prendilo e non ho
capito se posso fare il rumore per
distrarre dalle guardie cosa però è un
corpo l'ho preso l'altro chi chi è che
ha ammazzato gente porca vacca mi ha
visto cori potermi ha perso di vista
chi è che ha ammazzato gente in una
palestra scusami la rocca vacca al muro
a posso nascondermi dentro i cassonetti
wow è bellissimo se hai fatto benissimo
dove sarò filippo non lo sono
mago houdini sono un fenomeno che
spariscono così come veramente difficile
scansare le guardie anche perché non
puoi correre più veloce di così come
proviamoci lo distratto non è più
distratto porca vacca il giro fanno una
ronda e secondo livello ed è già un
casino come possibile
no no dove sono finito tipo métier nelle
scatole va bene mi piace un sacco la
musica tra l'altro fatto molto bene e ci
esci e se esci che non sapranno mai che
sei qua perfetto ciao
e stato veramente difficile
no non l'ho messo va messo nel
bagagliaio prima la sicurezza stradale i
carichi pesanti vanno nel bagagliaio
dove metto le cosa fa c'è una roba lì
l'arma del delitto la prendo a ciò che
se ppa sei morto definitivamente preso
preso tutto vai vai vai vai vai veloce
buono leggo benissimo è stato
difficilissimo
c'è veramente un casino se però verrà
cavicchio ciao mamma ho lavorato oggi è
visto che bravo ma io li butto nella mia
immondizia e corpi no perché non è che
come cioè non è proprio il massimo
interagisci questo gioco sarà mica
family friendly rondò amazon sta
parlando con il pulitore ci sono io
posso aiutarti
sì spero di sì vi sia stato molto
raccomandato cristo che sono
raccomandato la mamma sta uscendo che
c'è del sangue dopo li faccio io
già ma cosa è stata la madonna cosa
succede
venerdì 13 è stato far devo pulire il
sangue devo ma non è vero
devo pulire il sangue cioè i poliziotti
arrivano vero non sangue rico ok è morto
qualcuno poi arrivo io pulisco dicono a
noi ci siamo sbagliati non era sbagliato
un bel sono io che vedo male ho pulito
qua c'è una pozza prima non ci ha ridato
con con l'aspirapolvere col folletto sto
pulendo il sangue col folletto ma io sto
pulendo persona di corpo arca vacca
andrà dove sono mai andato bo questi
malviventi che si nascondono così bene e
seriamente cava cavalca vacca come la
polizia più veloce di me come questa
roba da coach alla ciambella va bene e
bellissimo senso però ok
devo andare a pulire ma porca perché se
uso l'aspirapolvere mi sente quindi dopo
anno
orecchie poliziotti ma sto in gioco
fatto bene la madonna veramente bene e
ora cavalcavia via via via piave via la
scuola edile cambia non mi possono si
reca per lo script i nella macchina la
polizia c'è solo questo nascondiglio
catch me if you can gara che c'è ma va
bene dunque è seriamente l'aspirapolvere
fa pure casino
ci mancava solo questo non ha veramente
un bordello cioè non possono mentre mi
segue continua a spirare oh mio dio
sei anni leggo dalla portiera all'altra
java dente scusate non so dove la porta
per guidare bene un anno e mezzo c'è
veramente o dio mamma ha visto che sto
pulendo in casa che bravo ci ho messo
una vita per fare suo livello era
impossibile la gamba sta a livelli così
ma sto uscendo ho finito di pulire i
sofà ho trovato due o tre dita
nel mentre però stai tranquillo bene
stato qua sono entrato dentro
dall'ascensore 2000 secondo scudetto
alle cose elemento nell'ascensore va
bene qua c'è più schifo dell'altro posto
the wall e prima che così è successo qua
ma in i clienti queste fanno esattamente
come fate a come tu cosa che fate per
farsi katia posso portarlo alla finestra
o bello questo interessante
bisogna fare qua c'è un corpo lì lo vedo
lo prendo è bene butto giù dalla
finestra anche questo
let's go le me no vi sono in cassa una
scrivania o write
devono solo andare via quindi perfetto
ragazzo livello è stato molto più
semplice di colori prima se te ne vai
però grazie entrato pulito uscito meglio
di prima
changes come il cambiamento in arrivo
tipo che cambia la sfida povero uso
un'altra roba comunque complimenti gioco
è molto interessata tipo viscera clean
up prof
solo è molto più anche più difficile in
realtà allora fammi capire se posso
schiacciare la polizia
la polizia però vedere spettacoli si
posso non schiacciarla ma come come come
passato in mezzo come
no vabbè aiuto aiuto amici come fa ma
come ha fatto a passare non vale è
passato in mezzo
devo sbloccare il passaggio qua sotto
che mi prendo i corpi mite che l'ultimo
corpo guarda dove barca va come faccio a
prenderlo non ci credo poi per favore
andare da tutt'altra parte che quando
casini la vita come faccia l'ultimo
corpo ci metto sei anni a puoi salire
spesso il tiro di nuovo la cosa della
barca mentre lui è sopra ci togliamo di
mezzo una guardia
no ci credo non ci credo dimmi che c'è
da una roba dimmi che posso nascondermi
un porco demonio un'ora e mezza per fare
sta roba è solo morto di nuovo
incastrare le guardie prima che
difficilissimo sono incasserà mi sono
incastrato io ma anche a un corpo
ragazzi
indovinate un po dove secondo voi da
questo taglio che farò il video ce
l'avrà fatta sì o no incredibile non so
come ma ok basta
vi prego via via dio mio o basse
basta va bene così è stato cio l'ansia
mamma rispondi tu al telefono che c'ho
voglia ragazzi è stato un bel gioco
istruttivo family friendly tutto figo
spero che vi sia piaciuto come al solito
solide per cercare un argomento non mi
piace anche vari social che come negli
dotata descrizione se non sono questi
iscrivetevi e noi ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo video dei ragazzi
[Musica]